we got a new backdrop thanks flame
challenge hey crazies I've been thinking
there's an idea we haven't given enough
thought inertia we defined it in a
previous video an object's ability to
resist changes in motion but then
question clone got involved what does
that really mean and well I just can't
help but answer the guy's questions
first let's get some perspective with a
little history even though real science
started with Galileo the story of motion
starts much much earlier
back when exact dates are a little hazy
there was this guy named Aristotle in
ancient Greece and he had some very bad
ideas introducing Aristotle clone the
natural state of all things is to be at
rest if you impart motion to a book does
it not stop of its own accord get get
out shoot how dare you do you know who I
am
you're just a clone of Aristotle all
right I know I've said this before but
I'll say it as many times as it takes
Aristotle was almost always wrong but
his idea sounded pretty believable so
humans were convinced he was right for
about 2,000 years fast forward to
Galileo real science began when Galileo
started doing experiments
you know actually testing our ideas
before claiming them as fact Galileo
discovered something very important
relativity no no no not the Einstein Ian
relativity just basic relativity we did
a video on it as part of a series but
here's the T ldw version steady motion
in a straight line for one observer
could easily be no motion for another
observer therefore they are the same
type of motion inertial motion inertial
as in inertia as in inert shah and root
words for the wind the point is when
Aristotle said this the natural state of
all things is to be at rest
he should have also included steady
motion in a straight line because that's
indistinguishable from being at rest and
this brings us to Newton and his
Principia Mathematica I have a copy of
this around here somewhere ah here it is
let's read shall we law 1 everybody
preserves in its state of being at rest
or of moving uniformly straight forward
Newton's first law actually defines
inertia well it's a tendency things have
to either stay still or keep steadily
moving like this or like this or even
this if you want to know what that car
video is all about go check it out on my
friend Jesse's channel he works out the
math behind it too but didn't that car
just stop yeah because there's this
pesky thing on earth called friction
without friction that car would have
just gone on forever the point I'm
trying to make here is that inertia is
not a force
I repeat inertia is not a force when you
take all the forces away inertia is what
remains thanks for liking and sharing
this video please subscribe if you'd
like to keep up with us and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy
in the last video we discussed where
size comes from come out response time
mr. koffice isn't sure what space is
anymore yeah that's actually a place
we're pretty stuck right now in quantum
physics it's just an environment in
which things play out it doesn't really
have any effect on the interactions in
general relativity it's something
tangible that can be stretched and
twisted but it still has to be a
continuous fabric otherwise the
equations aren't valid even way though
it's created just there and it isn't
made of anything more fundamental Joe
Craig always assumes space with energy
fields well like I said in the previous
answer space is just kind of there in
fact it already has to be there for our
models to work even in quantum field
theory there's an energy field for every
type of fundamental particle but those
fields still have to exist in a space
that's what a field is it's a value
assigned to every point in space no
space means no field Pablo Perez was
wondering if a calculus differential was
the same as a single point definitely
not it's always the space between two
points say you've got appointed five and
a point it's in the difference between
them is two so it's kind of like saying
there's a point at five and appointed
five plus two everybody still with me
you could make those points closer by
putting the second one at five plus one
instead or five plus point one or five
plus point zero zero zero zero zero one
if you make the difference so small that
you can never hope to measure it then we
call the difference between the two
points a differential we say that one is
it five and one is it five plus DX that
little tiny space but those are still
two different points the same goes for
volumes little volume differentials are
made of eight points and depending on
your choice of coordinates can have
different shapes but that's because
differentials always have some size
Daioh double wants to know what string
theory has to say about all this
they definitely go with solution number
three points have size which reminds I
asked you which of the three solutions
you thought was correct infinities
unoccupied pots or points with sized
points with size was the winner by
consensus although not by much because
very few of you actually voted in the
comments come on crazy work with me here
we did have some very witty people in
the
this time much appreciated anyway thanks
for watching everybody
see you in the comments